we've had a great week on on NBCSN and
it wraps up with letting you know how we
can raise more money for those who need
our assistance in this pandemic and
joining me to talk about that and how
you can raise money on behalf of music
cares kovat nineteen relief fund at a
watch party of one of my favorite Tom
Hanks films period end of story he knows
how I feel about that thing you do he is
one of the stars of that film getting
back together with the rest of the
wonders band later today on the
youtube.com slash the wonders live watch
party is Tom Everett Scott how are you
Tom hey I'm great rich hear your voice
how are you doing right back at you so
how did this all come about I know but
I'd like to for you to let everybody
know how this all came about well last
week I was facetiming with my buddies I
was out on his farm in Kentucky he was
taking a break from putting in fence
posts and he told me in his own words
that he has been social distancing for
years he recently joined Instagram he
had sworn off social media completely
until this happened and his daughter
convinced him to start posting hilarious
videos we were talking about those and
he said let's do something for the fans
so we called Jonathan Scheck and Ethan
Embry we got the band back together and
we decided to do a watch party on on
YouTube lives and it's in and the I
guess inspiration for this is paying
tribute to songwriter producer Adam
Schlesinger who passed away lost his
battle with Cove at 19 he wrote he wrote
the song that thing you do correct Tom
yes Adam Schlesinger wrote the song that
thing you do
we lost him way too soon there's only 52
years old
the man had incredible careers so talent
it had done many many different things
one of which being being nominated for
an Oscar for best song for that thing
you do and he he likes thread the needle
on this one he he had to write a song
that would be a hit in the 60s
had to have the the words that seen you
do there were 300 submissions for this
including one that Tom Hanks and
producer Gary gets men wrote themselves
but but Adams song prevailed and that's
the one that became a hit in the 90s as
a result of being in the film and and
it's just a perfect song it is a perfect
song and it's a perfect film as well so
how does this watch party gonna go down
who's involved and how can people get
involved okay so it's gonna start at
7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific on our
YouTube channel when she said
youtube.com slash the winners live it's
definitely the four wonders we are going
to make some noise for the health care
workers right at 7:00 p.m. Eastern
we are gonna press play together
everyone get your copies of the movie
get it queued up mm-hmm and we are going
to all press play together and watch the
movie we're gonna tell stories and laugh
and quote and sing along to the
theatrical version the 108 minute
original theatrical version how old were
you how old were you when you were on
the set there Tom so right on my 25th
birthday in 1995 Tom Hanks called me at
my apartment in New York to tell me that
he was going to cast me in the movie
after I had done it like a round of
auditions then I started learning the
drums for two months a month by myself
in a month with the band in LA and then
we started filming boy so two months
after September so like a round of you
know November in 1995 and it was one of
the greatest experiences of my life
I'm bad what is it like getting a call
from Tom Hanks at age 25 to say I've
written and I've directed a film and
it's very important to me and I'm gonna
cast you in a very important role it's
one of those moments where I think I
left my body and kind of watched it
happened from somewhere up around the
ceiling he was so cool about it he was
just like Hayes's Tom Scott I said yeah
I said it's Tom Hanks and he said I just
want you to know I remember when Ron
Howard called me at home to ask me to be
in his movie
splash and sand I always thought that
was a cool thing that he did so that's
why he called me personally it was it
was great I'm fantastic my hero you know
calling me it was it was so surreal such
a dream come true
and then everything after that becoming
friends with all the guys and having
that experience into this day being able
to still celebrate it is just you know
such a great thing and I saw obviously
Tom Hanks was hosting the Saturday Night
Live at home last weekend and at one
point as I think he was introducing
Chris Martin of Coldplay as the musical
guest he had his Playtone records
sweatshirt on and obviously Playtone is
a name of his of his company for so many
years his production company for so many
years is is he
and/or Liv Tyler potentially in the
offing later today on youtube.com slash
well we were all hoping that we were
gonna be able to get you know all these
great guests on onto this thing I know
that that Liv is probably that's not
gonna happen cuz she's in the UK be one
am for her she's got you know she's got
a gaggle of kids so I don't think she's
gonna make it but you know we're hoping
that we'll get like something from mr.
white tonight I know that Colin Hanks is
gonna join us he's got a couple other
special guests that are going to jump in
there love it so we'll see hey Tom I you
know you know I've told you many times
when certainly we're on the set of I'm
sorry where I was holding a goldfish and
people still tweet at me about my
goldfish on that set with Andrew
savaging you this is the goldfish rich
wow I don't think that's safe for work
right here on all of our our platforms
but this movie is special man you were
special in it and for you too you know
the other young Squires to return today
on behalf of MusiCares cove at 19 relief
fun it's really neat so as soon as I
heard about I'm like I have to have you
call in and and let's raise as much
money as possible Tom well I really
appreciate it rich thank you for helping
me spread the word I'm glad that you're
doing well and I wish you the best right
back at you that's Tom Everett Scott
follow him on Twitter Tom E Scott at Tom
a Scot right here on the Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here